on de l'assemblée générale j'ai
l'honneur de souhaiter la bienvenue à
l'organisation des nations-unies à son
excellence monsieur jaillir messias paul
sonar au président de la république
fédérative du brésil
que janvier et à prendre la parole
devant l'assemblée
bonjour à tous
monsieur le président de l'assemblée
générale monsieur habib ou l'achat reid
monsieur le secrétaire général des
nations unies monsieur antonio gutiérrez
chefs d'état et de gouvernement et chef
de délégation
mesdames et messieurs
c'est pour moi un honneur d'ouvrir de
nouveau la
différence de débat général de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
je suis ici pour vous décrire un brésil
très différent de celui qui vous ai
décrit dans les journaux ou que vous
voyez à la télévision le brésil a changé
a beaucoup changé depuis janvier 2019 en
effet ces deux dernières années et huit
mois nous n'avons pas eu une seule
affaire de corruption le brésil s'est
doté d'un président qui croie dont dieu
qui respecte l'armée qui valorise la
famille et qui
fait preuve de loyauté vis-à-vis de son
peuple
et ce n'est pas rien c'est une base
solide
si nous considérons que le brésil était
au bord du socialisme
les entreprises publiques aujourd'hui
sont rentables alors qu'elle l'a accusé
et des milliards de dollars en pertes et
notre banque nationale de développement
qui financer des projets dans des pays
communistes sans la moindre garantie
n'est plus dans cette situation c'est à
l'époque le peuple brésilien respecter
les engagements pris par la banque mais
tout a changé aujourd'hui le brésil que
je vous présente est un brésil nouveau
un pays qui a retrouvé sa crédibilité
un brésil doté du plus grand partenariat
public privé de toute son histoire
un programme bien réel actuellement en
cours de mise en oeuvre 100 milliards de
dollars ont été
débloqués en investissement et 20,3
milliards en concession dans le secteur
de l'infrastructure
34 aéroports et 29 terminaux portuaires
ont été mises en jeu moz mis aux
enchères
et nous avons
déjà garanti plus de 6 milliards de
dollars en contrats privés pour la
construction de nouveaux chemins de fer
un nouveau système de permis a été mise
en place un modèle qui ressemble à celui
en vigueur ici aux etats-unis et en
quelques jours nous avons reçu 14
demandes de
permis de construction
à hauteur de 15 milliards de dollars en
investissements privés nous avons
toujours prévu la revitalisation du
système ferroviaire au brésil au sein de
notre gouvernement est aujourd'hui
le résultat en est que la consommation
de carburants fossiles aimant importante
les coûts opérationnels associés aux
affaires au brésil notamment en matière
de production alimentaire ont également
baissé
des progrès notables ont été réalisés
dans le domaine de l'assainissement
également la plus grande vente aux
enchères dans l'histoire de ce secteur a
tu as eu lieu en avril le secteur privé
sera aujourd'hui chargé de
l'approvisionnement en eau et des
services de canalisation à rio nous
savons tous ce que les investisseurs
recherchent à vaste marché de
consommateurs d'excellents actifs une
prédiction de respect des contrats
conclus avec les investisseurs et un
gouvernement qui jouit de la confiance
je vais l'annoncer dans les prochains
jours nous allons bientôt pour tenir une
vente aux enchères des fréquences 5 g au
brésil et nous avons une agriculture
moderne une agriculture à faibles
émissions de carbone qui nourrit un
milliard de personnes dans le monde et
qui occupe pourtant moins de 8 % du
territoire national notre pays est doté
d'une législation environnementale la
plus exhaustive dans le monde notre coup
de forestiers par exemple est un exemple
pour d'autres pays le brésil est un pays
aussi vaste qu'un continent confronté à
des défis environnementaux colossaux
le brésil a une superficie de 8 5
millions de kilomètres carrés dans 66%
tous sont couverts de la végétation qui
était présente lorsque le pays et a été
découvert dans le biome amazonien par
exemple 84 % de la forêt est intacte
vierge
et abrite la plus riche biodiversité de
la planète je vous rappelle d'ailleurs
qu'elle amazonie
est équivalente à l'ensemble de l'europe
occidentale en termes de superficie
nous devrions obtenir au atteindre notre
objectif de neutralité climatique d'ici
à 2050 2060 les ressources humaines et
financières visant à renforcer les
agences environnementales ont été
doublés avec pour objectif d'éliminer la
déforestation illégale
et cette action importante eux porte
déjà ses fruits en amazonie par exemple
la déforestation a diminué de 30 2% au
mois d'août par rapport au mois d'août
de l'année dernière
quel autre pays dans le monde disposent
d'une politique de protection de
l'environnement
telle que la nôtre vous êtes tous
invités à venir visiter l'amazonie
mesdames et messieurs le brésil est en
exemple également en termes de
production énergétique en effet 83 % de
notre énergie provient de sources
renouvelables et à la coop 26 qui se
tiendra prochainement nous allons
chercher à établir un consensus sur les
règles
devant devant régir le marché des
crédits carbone les pays industrialisés
devraient
respecter leurs engagements en matière
de financement climatique
l'avenir des emplois verts
se trouve au brésil énergies
renouvelables l'agriculture durable la
juste riz des émissions
des faibles émissions l'assainissement
le traitement des eaux usées le tourisme
autant de secteurs qui vont créer de
tels emplois nous avons également
ratifié la convention interaméricaine
contre le racisme la discrimination
raciale et les formes connexes
d'intolérance et pour nous la famille
traditionnelle fondement de toute
civilisation la liberté de l'être humain
ne peut être accompli que par la liberté
de culte 14 % de notre territoire
national et notamment plus de 110
millions d'hectares
une zone aussi grande que l'allemagne et
la france réunies
est consacrée aux réserves des
populations autochtones et dans ces
régions six cent mille personnes vivent
en liberté et partage la volonté
grandissante de tirer profit de leurs
terres pour est consacrée à
l'agriculture et à d'autres activités
le brésil a toujours participé aux
opérations de maintien de la paix des
nations unies du suez au congo passant
par haïti et le liban nous avons
toujours a accueilli des réfugiés
l'opération accueil dirigée par notre
gouvernement
fédéral a déjà accueilli 400 milles
vénézuélien déplacés par la grave et
connaître crise économique et politique
provoqué par la dictature
polisarienne
l'avenir de l'afghanistan
ce site chez nous une grande inquiétude
nous
délivrerons des visas humanitaires
aux femmes hommes enfants et juju
afghan
de confession chrétienne
en fait 20e année commémorant les
attentats perpétrés contre les états
unis d'amérique le 11 septembre 2001 jeu
condamne de nouveau le terrorisme sous
toutes ses formes et en 2022 nous allons
tenir un siège au conseil de sécurité
des nations-unies je remercie d'ailleurs
tous les pays sont 81 au total sur 190
qui nous ont accordé leur confiance
cela reflète la politique étrangère
responsable promu par notre ministère
des affaires étrangères nous appuyons
d'ailleurs la réforme du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies où vous
souhaitons obtenir un siège permanent
la pandémie nous a tous pris au dépourvu
en 2020 nous déplorons bien sûr tous les
décès au brésil comme ailleurs dans le
monde
provoquée par le pandémie nous avons
toujours appuyé la lutte contre le virus
et le chômage simultanément et avec la
même responsabilité malheureusement les
mesures d'isolement aide les
confinements ont entraîné l'inflation et
de la flambée des prix des denrées
alimentaires dans le monde entier pour
aider les plus démunis contraint de
rester chez eux par les décisions des
gouverneurs et des mères toutes ces
personnes à qui ont perdu leurs sources
de revenus nous avons décidé de
délivrer une aide d'urgence de 800 $ à
chacune des 68 millions de personnes
concernées en 2020
je rappelle que nous avons achevé
l'année l'année de la pandémie 2020 avec
davantage d'emplois formels que ce que
l'on comptait en décembre 2010 9 grâce
au programme mise en oeuvre par notre
gouvernement
cela nous a coûté autour de 40 milliards
de dollars
au cours des sept premiers mois de cette
année 1 million 800 mille nouveaux
emplois ont été créés et j'aimerais
également vous dire que notre croissance
pour 2021 devrait s'élever à 5 % le
gouvernement fédéral a déjà distribué
plus de 260 millions de doses du vaccin
contre la colombie des plus de 140
millions de brésiliens
soit près de 90% de la population
d'adultes a reçu au moins une 12 80% des
populations autochtones
ont été pleinement vacciner
et en novembre nous espérons pouvoir
d'accéder tous ceux qui le souhaitent au
brésil a
cependant
gouvernement n'a pas
été en faveur d'une obligation vaccinale
des impasses sanitaires comme on
l'appelle depuis le début de la pandémie
nous avons toujours
été en faveur de l'autonomie des
médecins dans le cadre des recherches de
traitement comme recommandé par le
conseil fédéral de médecine brésilien
j'ai moi-même
été traités
contre le coc zidane et je respecte en
toutes circonstances les relation
médecin patient pour ce qui est des
médicaments être utilisés notamment
l'utilisation en dehors de l'usagé
indiqué sur l'étiquette 1 nous ne
comprenons pas que certains pays
aient une plus grande partie des médias
s'oppose à ce type de traitement
l'histoire et la science les jugeront le
7 septembre le jour de l'indépendance
des millions de brésiliens
ont manifesté de manière pacifique et
patriotique la plus grande manifestation
de notre histoire a ainsi été organisée
pour proclamer que le peuple ne
renoncera pas à la démocratie ni à ses
libertés individuelles une manifestation
qui vise également à appuyer le
gouvernement
le brésil vit une ère nouvelle comme je
l ai déjà dit en termes économiques nous
avons connu une performance sans
précédent parmi les pays émergents mon
gouvernement a rétabli la crédibilité du
brésil c'est une des destinations les
plus prometteuses en matière
d'investissement et c'est ici à
l'assemblée générale que nous pouvons
imaginer un monde plus libre amont plus
démocratique plus prospère et plus
pacifique que dieu nous bénisse tous
merci
[Applaudissements]
on ne vient en afrique au nom de
l'assemblée générale je tiens à
remercier le président de la république
fédérative du brésil de l'allocution
qu'il vient de prononcer je prie le
protocole de bien vouloir accompagner
son excellence